there's a famous experiment where they
took students law students
and they said okay we're going to give
you a material for real case and some of
you would be uh you know the plaintiff
or the other one who would feel that
it's the defendant
and
and you know read the materials and
and then
tell us what you think the fair uh
judgement would be
and you could see that this mere uh
division
they're giving them the role when you
were neither blended or defended change
the way they are like the same fact the
same data
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret corps adventures j ventures
riverside fm fusion vc
birthright excel j impact leap google
for startups and hippo and in media
partnership with ctec
hello hello and welcome to another
episode of 20 minute leaders this is a
really really cool episode about
mediation and about conflict resolution
looking at it from a different angle i
learned a ton from this episode and i
really enjoyed it and i hope you do as
well
meet dr tal rotman a partner and chair
of alternative dispute resolution and
pearl cohen a prominent law firm in
israel he has extensive experience in
mediating and litigating stakeholders
disputes in startup companies previously
he was a consultant at the new york
office of mckinsey and company taught in
tel aviv university school of law and
clerked for the israeli supreme court he
holds a phd in law a master's in
psychology an l11 commercial law llb and
ba in accounting from tel aviv
university he also earned an llm in
corporate law from new york university
where he was a hauser scholar
enjoy this episode
[Applause]
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
so much for joining me all the way from
the peril cohen offices how are you
thanks for having me here everything is
cool here you know they're 30 30
something degrees or centigrade so you
don't understand how hot it is but still
life in terms of here
i love it well it's your favorite
california eventually exactly as well
you know your work is so interesting and
i'm so excited to understand a little
bit better what you do um you know
within pearl cohen your
partner and chair of alternative dispute
resolution and with experience in
mediating and litigating stakeholders
disputes and startup companies we're
also with mckinsey and company uh
lecturing in tulviv university
and you were it clerked for the israeli
supreme court with a phd in law masters
in psychology so and and many many more
titles both in academia academia and
elsewhere
i'm not going to do it justice but but
safe to say that you've had a hand in
working with fascinating people and
fascinating organizations um at world
class level and so i'm especially
excited to hear sort of what motivated
you throughout your career and how did
you sort of figure out your own path and
what's important to you so tal thank you
very much for spending these 20 minutes
with me
perfect well um you know everything uh
happened by mistake like if you plan
things and good luck right so
it's it's not really the things that
happen the way you plan them they just
move along and you try to enjoy the
other way
so so what's what do you enjoy because
you've you've sort of done so many
incredible things where where do you get
your own enjoyment from so
at this point everything comes together
with the speaker's mediation thing
because uh i've been litigating places
in israeli courts for many years now and
it's a very inefficient way to solve
problems between a bigger first year
and people get there and represent them
and you know they make a living doing
that but this is not uh what i would
recommend to
to my brother or if they're a family
member
um who
find himself in a world sovereign
dispute
it's just especially when it comes to
high tech comfort so you know hiking
companies they they grow very fast they
start they're all very often on a very
trendy basis so
inexperienced people
and then in some point if they're lucky
it blooms
right then everything changes and
changes very very fast
and uh at this stage
so many things could happen like there's
so many so much friction
and uh it's a fascicle you know so much
that people who
need to be an angel not to have someone
here
and some arguably to dispute
and what i think it's it's very sad to
see people that follow the company
together that were good friend uh they
had a vision
and now they're some sort of a stupid
dispute that ended up in the figures
because then the company could go down
the drain as well so which is not a
matter of just
helping uh people those are helping the
company
and it's really really nice because it
brings together what i've done in the
past which is uh in the world of law of
accounting of psychology of litigation
and uh the whole idea of
radiation is that uh instead of going to
a judge
or arbitrator which is essentially the
judge that you hired right the private
judgment to the judge there's someone
who needs to hear this side and that
side and then decide who's right like
the mediator is in a totally different
philosophy that someone that um
is experienced in here both partly
and he had absolutely no power to decide
on anything
the only thing i could do is bring
together people
uh where they say okay we agree and we
sign a contract basically resolving the
issue
and and so you have absolutely nothing
right there's no store there's no
decision flower it's basically
your experience
um
what you've seen what you've gathered
throughout life
and and the outcome could be remarkable
because instead of people ruining their
relationship
spending the israelite minds from here
at the court
spending really large amounts of money
and uh on lawyers and legal fees losing
uh night to your sleeping at night and
they end up ruining the company so they
end up working for nothing and it's
really really fair and when you manage
to to do this trick
where they're all happy
then
it's like magic right it's just people
that uh they feel
unburdened
with uh with what they're
you know carrying their
uh
a dispute is such a heavy burden
and they're so relieved they're thankful
so it's really rewarding
and
it i definitely can i can feel the sense
of of sort of
coherence and what you're saying and how
you're bringing together these all these
facets from your experience from from
psychology to accounting to commercial
law to corporate law and and and and
bringing that together to understanding
you know where mediation is taking place
but what what allowed you to come to
that realization i haven't met
many people
that
that are that are as excited and
passionate about this sort of this idea
of mediation that you're coming from in
this intersection of disciplines
how did this start for you how did you
get here
it truly sounded gradually right no
one's with the female
old smart and wise it usually you start
out like a guided recklet and you gather
some information along the way
and you're getting better right so
i've actually look i've been
my profession to represent people in
courts i see courts that when sometimes
you win sometimes you lose but hopefully
you win more than you lose but it's
picked up right it shuts the problematic
prospects people are always so
disappointed coming out of it
um
and they're so empty you know and then
they fixed it
such a
disappointment even if they won the
character just want to get rid of it at
the end of the day
and the great thing about radiation
is that you have
hope that the judge does not have
so at the end of the day it's much about
economic and
uh collective psychology
than anything else because imagine two
people are coming in front of a judge
that each one is uh he knows that the
judge can decide whether the deal that
you will decide or she
so they each one would tell
just part of the story what maybe the
truth but not the whole truth
and uh
then as where
as a mediator you can meet people's
different so you would sit with the
party and what what whatever did they
tell you
is uh another continent
so you would not reveal it without their
crew and they tell you what the real
story here
and then you hear the real story from
the other side and then sometimes you
see so much of the new avenues many new
revenues
um potential solutions that they don't
see
and um
how much of it comes down to
misunderstandings miscommunication
misunderstandings between people
that are not necessarily being totally
open and transparent about what they
really feel or what they really need or
want in a situation
okay so this is where uh going through
psychology after providence uh where you
have the bias to accommodate your
bankers uh you know what filthy con man
[Music]
for those experiments but at the end of
the day what what is very interesting is
that people
um they have a self-certain buyer right
so even if they agree on the fact that
there's no
argument about the fact they would still
think
that you know things leaving to their
favor so there's a famous experiment
where they took students law students
and they said okay we're going to give
you a material for real case and some of
you would be uh
you know the plaintiff is the other one
who is the defendant
and
and you know read the materials and
and then
tell us what you think the fair uh
judgment would be
and you could see that this mere uh
division
they're giving them the role when you're
neither blended or defended change the
way they analyze the same fact the same
data
and that's without the motion of
baltimore without being personally
involved in anything all that so people
would actually look at the same picture
and i feel differently about it you you
think you're right and then maybe you
are right for your perspective and but
but your friend or your ex-friend who is
now your enemy uh now uh it fits right
from from left side and start dive as an
observer you can see well here i could
see
why both of you are
feeling this way
and maybe there's a solution that would
keep
uh both of you all both not happy at
least
there would be some refinement that
could make sense right and if it makes
them both parties agree and you have a
resolution and that will be finalized
with it
this corkscrew has ended uh in few hours
instead of a few months or years and a
lot of people you know the good savings
are running here
but
you come with a solution who is
sometimes a business solution
but remember if you go to court or
arbitration
you have to stick to legal argument so
you come to your lawyer you tell them a
story and you think oh you know this is
not relevant this is not rather this oh
at this point yeah let's make the whole
case around it why because there's some
legal right involved there which was a
great role so there's a legal argument
so they take reality they translate it
into little words
and then the court decide or on the
legal stuff but this is not the real
argument the real audio there's a
business argument sometimes that's
something is emotional argument
sometimes it's people who have a
different interest or you know different
opinion
um
and in court you have to brave
everything in terms of legal rights
and this
kind of distorts everything right and
then you lose
control over it because you cannot
control it to the lawyers if you don't
understand how what they're saying and
they come back to say okay we want we
luck whatever
you totally love control but if you were
there
uh and we talked about the real fishery
with samurai booster the tensor
and uh has the incentive to help you
because otherwise you know it's a
failure for me as well
right
sometimes the magic happen
is there ever an advantage to going to
sort of arbitrage or
or legal proceedings in court rather
than a mediator it almost seems to me
trivial that mediator is sort of always
the better option because it allows for
everything that a court allows except
for that final decision
with
sort of this cognitive psychology and
sort of the emotional aspect of of the
real story being told
look that in reality most people don't
go to media yeah why and i think that's
a lot i think that's a rocket failure i
just wrote an article about that ah okay
to market failure because people think
you know i i've actually tried to
separate this guy i tried to be
reasonable with him he wouldn't lift him
right so right now if i tried as big as
of sleep of their actually
they're they're comfortable negotiating
so it's not that they come to me after
they haven't talked to each other
usually they did talk to each other and
fail so they think why would a third
person who knows nothing about the
dispute who knows nothing about that
how could he be helpful
and then the answer for that is a
because i get the information that you
don't share with each other
right because it's just that you're not
telling each other they're all true and
for good reasons because otherwise it
will it will hurt you back in court
and because um
i cannot decide so i can only offer
something that would be a win-win
otherwise nothing happened but you know
the downside and that's a potential
downside have one has to admit um
of
mediation could pray so you could come
to a mediator you would spend
time not as much time as you would spend
in court you would spend money not as
much money do you spend it
but at the end of the day they would
know there wouldn't be any fissure
because this is not how this thing works
it's not about deciding who's right or
who's wrong
it's about trying to understand the
interest of all parties involved and
try to fight some middle ground
now if there's absolutely no legal
ground like there are a rebuilt
situation like that maybe there's no
reason to read it but it could be very
few other cases right where there's
nothing to talk about right in fact i
just want to recap to one of the first
sentences that we started with and the
way that you described most of the
disputes that we're observing in the
market today um they're not necessarily
you know
these really intelligent and complicated
disputes right you're you know they're
they may be you know it's just silly
ones that need to be overcome and that's
also why i referred later to sort of the
miscommunication question how do we
optimize a market that will allow for
mediators or mediation to be a leading
idea for people that are in dispute
because until now if you were to ask me
30 minutes ago michael what would you do
if you had you know
a really deep conflict with a business
partner so somebody of that sort i don't
think that i would immediately think of
mediation hopefully i would eventually
but it wouldn't be trivial for me
right now i think you're right but for
most people it's not prevalent with a
treatable like for me either i mean it's
something that i've learned
uh i've been the witness to so many
people fail their litigation or their
faith
they say even if they win
you know they say that the lawyers
always win because they get fed either
way right
but clients or clients always lose
because even if they win
well it's retired for sure how do we
optimize for the market so that it's
trivial for me to think about the
mediation
so a lot of it i think is education
people don't know um
and they're not familiar with radiation
they don't understand the logic behind
it they think you know we're gonna go to
a third party who knows nothing about
the dispute and this guy uh not only
doesn't know anything he cannot decide
either so it's up to us and we tried to
decide and tried to settle but we
couldn't so why would he be able to
refer
and i think you know especially talking
to business people and people understand
the dynamic of information girls or
cognitive
dieter
they should understand they should take
the benefit because
um very involved
the
things like being overly optimist
about your kids
or having a self-serving fire thinking
that oh my goodness is much stronger
than i lived
and and so forth
this
actually uh
makes you go
and make the wrong decision right you go
to court thinking that you're going to
win no one goes to court thinking oh
it's going to lose but guess what comes
with the blues
right and sometimes
so sometimes right right look
i've now i've
been representing the company where
actually it was the hydra company
uh we started like youth success and one
of the founders
got a bit crazy when you actually got
really crazy it was very very
not too often you see something like
that but that destroyed the company
because they couldn't they couldn't find
a business
way to go uh
together
and there's a calculated valuation of 40
million dollars i mean it was running to
the ground just a lot of
all the promises and now
they're fighting over a corpse there's
nothing there wow the pattern
a lot it's just it's just a tragedy you
know people are just
um invented so much in it and i lost
everything and the only reason is
because they failed to struggle
and it's really really hard to settle
sometimes because
people are still
you know they're trapped in the love
that they think oh you know i see
reality right
but that but reality is uh it's very
subjective
i love that i love that uh i obviously
you know we can keep talking about this
for hours i just wanted to point out i i
just love the fun fact about the tenor
saxophone and and the jazz band i i'm a
huge jazz
jazzy
you know fan myself playing both the
tenor and all to myself so i'm already
booking you for a jam session at some
point tell me a little bit about sort of
following your own curiosity and and
passion
how does this play into to your own life
how do you maintain sort of authentic
with yourself and what you want to do
which obviously ended up leading you
also to mediation as well as just
playing
i keep listening to myself like when i
work and i get vote fairly quickly i you
know think about what i'm going to do
to change their
there's always there's so much
interesting things happening in the
world so it's always a river
a new path you can take like music music
that's for me look i haven't
um i hit the first music lesson three
years ago i you know i couldn't play a g
i didn't know what a g was wow i
couldn't identify it on the cliff i
couldn't but within now
like in two hours time like i've ever
a bunch of cloud cloaks and we'll be
playing together so it's really really
nice and i really enjoyed it that's a
huge world that was open for uh
just just two years ago and
for years i thought well you're not too
old to start but at the end of the day
it's really more about believing in
yourself and uh
and rising to the challenge because view
of brain is a very sophisticated machine
and it still works even if the uh it's
like a you know age so uh yeah it should
definitely be
young people those people
look the drummer the the drummer is the
woman who's over 30 years old they used
to be a judge
right so uh it's quite amazing to see
her coming and and playing the clubs
right and
okay she's not the best drummer ever but
i'm not the best factor of a player ever
and we still enjoy it so it's like
thank you so much for this awesome
conversation i loved it
really inspiring um
i think that you know just you know we
talked about a lot of differences uh
between you know litigation core
mediation i think that part of part of i
think the the aha moment for me here is
also understanding that at the end there
is meaning to how quickly you understand
that you're in conflict or that you have
some discrepancy in in reality
perceptions
and sort of obviously if everybody in
the world understood that we perceive
reality very subjectively and it's not
necessarily the reality then things
would be much better but but it sounds
to me that also mediation has the
opportunity to be to enter much
sooner and quicker
into the flow of a conflict and
obviously we're talking about cognitive
psychology and emotions the the more the
conflict persists the more hardwired we
become with our own perspective reality
and so uh i'm a i'm excited to read you
know what you published and and it's
fascinating to think that there may be a
market failure here so tal thank you
very very much
thank you very much
you